so we're here to talk to you
about
the picture
no sarah i don't know
this was the moment the murder squad
arrested sarah everard's killer wayne
cousins a police officer one of their
own do you know where sarah is
right
but he did know these blurred images
from a passing car show cousins
confronting sarah in the street six days
earlier
the pictures give no hint of the horror
to come
the off-duty constable handcuffed and
arrested her its thought for breaking
covered lockdown rules
minutes later he drove her away trapped
in the back of his hire car helpless
terrified
but i think it's got to be at some stage
when she's realized
wait a minute where are we going you
know he's heading towards dover so
there's got to be something happening
between
london and dover where
and her feeling completely powerless
yes i mean being handcuffed obviously as
we know is
you know it is restrictive for a reason
right and so i think
it doesn't really bear thinking about
that she's you know she's powerless to
know what happens next
um and it's it's really sad to think
that she's that quite scary situation
that she's in at that point
the prosecutor said sarah a marketing
executive would never have got into
cousin's car willingly her boyfriend
described her as savvy and streetwise
not gullible
but she had been out visiting a friend
at a time when all social meetings were
banned and cousins use that to dupe her
the only reason that i can think of in
my experience as a police officer is
that he's had to get her into that car
somehow and the main way to get her into
that car is to put under arrest and one
of the witnesses that has come forward
in that inquiry that they found
said that they saw sarah being
handcuffed
what do you think cousins
might have said to her to convince her
that she was being rightfully arrested
well i don't know i mean
he could have made up a law he could
have said anything he wanted to to get
her into the car i mean he could have
used covid as a as a reason to get her
into the back of the car and said you're
breaching covered rules and
arrested you know sarah wouldn't
necessarily known every single law and
he could have made one up to get her in
the back of the car
at the time cousins was a metropolitan
police constable he protected vip
buildings and carried a firearm
he has never explained why he kidnapped
raped and strangled sarah
in court her family read out moving
statements
her mother susan said in the morning i
wake up to the awful reality that sarah
is gone in the evenings at the time she
was abducted i let out a silent scream
don't get in the car sarah don't believe
him run
her father jeremy said all my family
want is sarah back with us no punishment
that you receive will ever compare to
the pain and torture that you have
inflicted on us
sarah's body was found in remote
woodland near ashford kent a week after
she vanished
cousins had burnt her remains
police don't know exactly where and when
cousins murdered sarah but they do know
that for a while he stored her body here
hidden amongst this rubbish under a
freezer
then cousins came back
and using some kind of trolley
brought sarah's body 250 yards or so
into the woods and left her in this
shallow water
simon harding explained how police
reacted when they knew sarah's killer
was one of their own
when they found out that it was a police
officer
it was something that would stay with me
certainly
before i left the met that stayed with
me for the rest of my life police
officers do not view wayne cousins as a
police officer
they view him as a murderer
who happens to be a police officer
rather than the other way around a
police officer who is a murderer and
it's a really important thing you know
he doesn't hold the same values as a
police officer he doesn't have the same
personality that we do you know he's a
very sick
very dangerous individual who should
never have been near a uniform
cousins will be sentenced in the morning
the prosecutor urged the judge to jail
him for the rest of his life
martin brunt sky news at the old bailey